One of the things that I learned while I
was going through this was the meaning
of the name Israel because Jacob
eventually it gets named Israel and I'm
jumping ahead a little bit tender to the
next lecture,
but Israel and so he's also the father
of Israel and the father of the 12 sons
who make up the 12 tribes of Israel,
but what Israel means is he who
struggles with God and that's such an
interesting idea because it's again,
a psychological idea and that's why I
said earlier that it isn't obvious in
the old testament what it means to
believe in God because what Jacob does
struggle with God and I think that
that's a really good characterization of
an ethical life because if you're trying
to lead an ethical life,
that's what you're doing is you're.
You're struggling.
Like blind belief isn't helpful because
you don't know what you're believing in.
Like.
It's just not that helpful,
but if you're possessed by,
by the desire to orient yourself
properly,
but also confused by the,
by the existential structure of the
world,
which we all are.
Then then what you're doing when you're
trying to orient yourself properly in
life is struggling ethically and in
Jacob actually gets quite hurt.
He wrestles with God,
literally God dislocates his,
his,
his thigh.
And so the idea there is watch the hell
out,
right?
The thing that you're contending with,
his powerful,
although you can contend with it,
that's the thing that's so interesting,
but you know,
you do it at some genuine peril,
which I think is exactly right,
but the idea that Israel,
so there's Israel,
the state,
let's say in Israel,
the promised land and all of that,
but there's this more important idea
which is again,
a psychological idea which is the state
of Israel,
which is the promised land is the state
that everyone who wrestles with God
exists in and that's not happy,
naive belief in,
you know,
uh,
an eternally blessed afterlife.
It's not that it's not a wish
fulfillment,
it's,
it's to be actively engaged in life,
in the difficulties of life.
Right?
And trying to find the path because
that's what wrestling with God is trying
to find the path.
And that seems to me what belief means
fundamentally in the Old Testament and
perhaps in the new testament as well as
that belief is expressed in trying to
find the path.
And that's an ethical struggle and it's
a real struggle.
It's the struggle of life.
So as long as you're willing to engage
in that struggle,
then hypothetically you have the divine
behind you.
And so I believe that.
I think that's true because the other
thing I see is that the people who set
things right so that the,
the,
the horrible forces of cosmic
destruction don't do us in the people
who are trying to set things right are
the ones that are struggling ethically
and so and that there is a redemptive
element to that.
And I don't think there's any way of
being cynical about that.
So.
Well,
so thank you.
Will.
Thank you.